we are learning that modernist vaccine
has an efficacy rate ranging from nearly
40 percent to just over 50 percent for
children younger than six now at face
value that might not seem like
eye-popping results but modernist chief
medical officer told us parents should
be reassured that the vaccine will
protect their kids
the most recent phase of modernist kid
cove trials revealed that two doses of
its vaccine have a 51 percent efficacy
rate for children six months to 2 years
old and a 37 percent efficacy rate for
children to under 6 years old what would
you say to parents who are worried about
giving their babies the vaccine well
look i think the results should comfort
you dr paul burton is modernist chief
medical officer
people can be reassured and confident
that these kids will get safely
protected against disease the trials
were primarily conducted during kovitz
omicron wave and modernist says the
vaccine appeared to generate the same
volume of antibodies in children as it
does in 18 to 24 year olds why did you
want to enroll your kids in this study
we wanted them vaccinated as soon as
possible and we also just very much
wanted to see
you know vaccine trials move forward so
that this youngest group
of kids could also get protected and
rodriguez's twins theo and sam were
participants in moderna's latest round
of trials at the university of wisconsin
she told us it was important to her
family because her husband and mother
while vaccinated both had pre-existing
conditions that put them at higher risk
for kovid's most severe effects
that's theo getting one of his shots in
november when he and his brother turned
five the rodriguez family learned that
theo had received modernist vaccine and
sam received a placebo they unenrolled
sam from the study so he could get the
pfizer vaccine are you glad you got this
done yeah yeah rodriguez told us the
experience has been a huge relief
the last few years have been nothing
that we would have ever imagined having
vaccines for
these youngest kids feels like a light
at the end of the tunnel
now as for side effects dr burton told
us some modern trial patients did
experience injection site pain or a
low-grade fever both normal reactions
the company's announcement comes as the
fda says making a vaccine available for
kids younger than five is one of its
highest priorities only after careful
and thorough analysis of relevant data
gail nancy thank you can i just say it's
so good to see you in person good to
have you in the studio good to be here
to nancy chen